[Musique]
bonjour pour commencer je citerai
manimal qui disait aujourd'hui je reçois
sébastopol figueiro sébastopol bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes l'homme qui peut
changer d'apparence à sa guise
amaguiz alors la première question qu'on
se pose c'est ça c'est votre apparence
de base ou c'est vous qui avez choisi
ben c'est pas pensez vraiment que ça
c'est le genre de physique qu'on faisait
alors comment vous faites un peu comme
arturo brachetti le transformiste vous
mettez un drap et hop vous êtes en
europe c'est pas exactement ça ah oui on
est vraiment sur un autre physique alors
comment vous faites
en fait je pense à quelqu'un et je me
transforme directement c'est là que ça
se passe
donc là par exemple si vous pensez à gpa
monica bellucci ou michel boujenah vous
pouvez je peux c'est dommage on n'a pas
pensé à la même personne c'est que je
peux vous faire changer d'apparence de
ses cibles
oui on fait comment il faut touches l et
pensez à votre meilleure amie quoi je
suis franc que tu mon meilleur ami on se
connaît depuis qu'on est en france et
c'est fou pensez à votre soeur
incroyable penser à la première personne
que vous avez vu nu je suis sophie
bouvier c'est ça non ah oui dont michel
away
pensez à votre première petite amie on
habitait dans un petit village vous êtes
revenir sur moi je me permets quelque
chose d'un petit peu fou fou là je suis
extrêmement fans de riels ce que vous
pouvez pour ça je connais pas rihanna
grande bâtisse du cléac'h qui chante b
du bella à mme manney big spender have
my money remettez moins gros re savais
que je peux changer le lieu aussi à bon
et comment vous faites ça va se lever
pour ça
bhl aller où bon je reviens chez moi je
ne cache pas que c'est pas super bien
salut c'est pas du tout ce que tu crois
[ __ ] tu m'as fait peur à temps et non
mais je suis qui moi tu es mon frère guy
bavois l'a jamais de l'avant les frères
ben tu restes à la maison ce sont deux
sets à zéro et que j'ai imaginé le pire
tu te fais des histoires dans ta tête et
6 e mail ils changent d'apparence kang
ho son économie comme disait mon tonton
michel abonne toi tu verras ça fait pas
mal sinon il ya les vidéos du lab tous
les vendredis à 18 heures sur le site
voilà